bien pues en este vídeo hablar de la
fórmula que probablemente es la más
famosa en las finanzas y es la de black
angels y es nombrada así por estos tres
caballeros de acá el primero de ellos es
fisher black éste es marshall y ellos
realmente sentaron las bases para lo que
llevó al modelo de black and soul o la
fórmula de black eyed shows y por eso el
nombre y este de aquí es bot verón quien
realmente tomó lo que es black and soul
y lo llevó a otro nivel para realmente
obtener el modelo e interpretaciones y
dicha fórmula y estos tres hombres
quienes ganaron el premio nobel en
economía excepto por el desafortunado
hecho de que fisher black falleció antes
de que recibiera el premio pero a mayor
soul y voz
verón obtuvieron el premio nobel por su
trabajo y la razón por la cual es una
gran idea por la cual es digna de un
premio nobel de hecho hay bastantes
razones que hasta podría ser todo una
serie de vídeos de esto pero en sí es
porque la gente ha estado negociando con
opciones de acciones o negociando
opciones desde hace mucho mucho tiempo
las ha estado comprando y
lo cual fue la mayor parte de los
mercados financieros hasta ahora pero no
son una buena forma o una manera fácil
de poner nuestra mente en matemáticas en
torno a de cómo evaluar una opción la
gente simplemente tenía noción de las
cosas que le importaban y asumiré que en
especial los negociadores de opciones
tienen la noción de las cosas que a
ellos les importaban y esto en cuanto se
trataba de negociar opciones pero
nosotros realmente no teníamos un marco
analítico para esto y esto es lo que
hace la fórmula de black and soul pero
antes de que nos sumerjamos en esta
aparentemente espeluznante fórmula pues
es de lo que más vamos a hablar con
suerte empezará a lucir mucho más
amigable de lo que luce ahora entonces
empecemos con un poco de intuición pues
las cosas que nos importan de esto es
que si estuviéramos pensando acerca del
precio de las opciones sobre acciones
entonces te va a interesar el precio de
la opción te importará el precio de
ejercicio y especialmente te importará
qué tan alto o bajo sea el precio que
alcancen las acciones y sea relativo al
precio de ejercicio
a importar también una tasa de interés
libre de riesgo la tasa de interés libre
de riesgo que se mantiene cuando
pensamos en el valor presente de algo si
quieres descontar o traer al valor
presente o al día de hoy algo tendrás
que por supuesto pensar en dicho en
dicha tasa cuánto tiempo entonces tengo
para ejercer esta opción realmente es
una pregunta clave también pero bueno
ahora también vamos a enfocar en que es
de importancia la volatilidad de la
acción que está representada por la
desviación estándar suena algo
fantástico pero voy a dar un ejemplo
para imaginarlo digamos que tenemos aquí
dos acciones esta es la primera su
comportamiento va a ser nuestro
subyacente número 1 nuestra acción
número 1 y luego este va a ser el camino
que va a recorrer nuestra acción número
2 en cuanto a sus precios de altas y
bajas que en si eso es lo que representa
la volatilidad que como ves esta acción
número 2 tiene muchísima más volatilidad
pues también puedes fijarte en qué tan
dispersa está de la media o qué tanto
tiene como de dispersión respecto
a su valor medio entonces esta segunda
tiene muchísima más volatilidad o una
alta desviación estándar que también
tienes que cuidar los logaritmos de
regreso de lo cual hablaré en el próximo
vídeo y para la acción número uno
tendremos entonces una baja volatilidad
una baja volatilidad y puedes imaginar
opciones o más variables con las cuales
estés tomando acciones de altísimas
volatilidad eso un alto sigma como ese
que tenemos por aquí y esto se va a
llevar el valor de nuestra opción hacia
arriba entonces by le va el precio de
nuestra opción cuando tienes algo así
pues observa la media del valor de la
acción entonces va siguiendo este camino
y en este caso la opción podría explorar
la media y ejercerla cuando a uno le
convenga ya sea si estás en una opción
de compra o venta entonces tú decides si
es el momento correcto para ejercerla y
así es como se siente negociar opciones
llama las más variables es que las
opciones vayan cambiando su precio
constantemente y pues podría ser como
algo
y si ahora vamos a hablar de esto
observa la fórmula de black angels y
bueno la fórmula que tengo por aquí es
para una opción de compra europea una
opción europea la cual es un tanto
similar a la opción de venta europea
pero en este caso es una opción de
compra y recuerda que una opción de
compra europea es matemáticamente tan
simple como una opción de compra
americana pero la cual cambia en que se
ejerce únicamente al final del ejercicio
y la opción americana se ejerce en todo
momento o en cualquier momento y ahora
digamos lo que intuitivamente está por
aquí donde este primer término de aquí
es el precio inicial de la acción no
subyacente luego está multiplicada por n
de 1 donde de 1 es esta parte de aquí
abajo luego es el precio de ejercicio
atraído a valor presente que este es el
valor de descuento multiplicado por n 2
donde de 2 toma esto de acá y de 1 y de
2 son valores muy importantes los cuales
definen casi todo el valor de la opción
y vamos a ver qué significa ndx esta es
una función de distribución de
probabilidad
a la cual se distribuye en normal normal
estándar y entonces y lo voy a explicar
exactamente en este espacio para no
abarcar más y entonces hacer una función
de distribución de probabilidad que nos
dice que esta función va a estar acotada
entre dos valores pues al ser una
probabilidad nos va a arrojar un valor
que va a estar entre 0 y 1 pues es una
probabilidad y no puede ser negativa y
tiene que ser siempre menor que 1 y
entonces esta es la probabilidad la cual
nos va a afectar nuestro precio de la
opción que va a ser entonces qué tan
alto o bajo base y esto es pensado
matemáticamente entonces este precio de
subyacentes como ponderado por esta
probabilidad que está aquí la cual es
menor que 1 y ahora de esta manera
pensemos lo que cada pieza de la fórmula
nos está diciendo
primeramente esto de aquí está tratando
con el precio inicial de la acción el
precio inicial de la acción la cual está
siendo multiplicada por este por esta
función que es una probabilidad y
entonces esencialmente aquí es lo que
estamos obteniendo
luego esta segunda parte que está el
precio del ejercicio multiplicado por
esta probabilidad de de 2 y el precio de
ejercicio es traído a valor presente es
esencialmente lo que estamos pagando y
ahora como vamos a hacer esto como es
que sabemos que hay que ejercer nuestra
opción todo esto de aquí tiene bastante
sentido pues el precio de subyacente -
el precio del ejercicio donde
definitivamente lo que tenemos que hacer
es que este de 1 y de 2 que inicialmente
son términos muy grandes al hacerlos
probabilidad nos ayudan a calcular
nuestro precio de la opción y ahora esta
parte de aquí porque traemos nuestro
precio de ejercicio a valor presente con
esta tasa de descuento por así nombrar
la que nos ayuda a traer a valor
presente las cosas y si tienes dudas o
te sientes confundido en esto puede
revisar vídeos anteriores donde hablo de
esto y es importante traer la valor
presente puesto que nuestro precio de
las acciones están al día de hoy al
igual que nuestro precio de la opción
queremos calcularlo al día de hoy
entonces por eso nuestro precio de
ejercicio lo traemos a valor presente y
luego por aquí abajo en d1 y d2 y te das
cuenta estamos haciendo un cociente
del precio de las acciones entre el
precio de ejercicio lo cual es tomado
para el logaritmo natural el cual está
definiendo casi el valor de d1 y d2 el
cual también es el tamaño del numerador
tomado para nuestra función de
distribución que significa que tan alta
será la probabilidad y ayuda a definir
el precio que esta opción tendrá lo cual
no nos hace demasiado sentido y luego
todo esto va a tener algunos valores por
eso hay mucha relación entre el precio
de las acciones y el precio de ejercicio
y ahora otra cosa en la que me voy a
enfocar bastante tiempo es algo que la
gente concentra demasiado para poder
operar las opciones y es la volatilidad
pues con nuestra intuición con alta
volatilidad sube el precio de la opción
y veamos cómo se refleja en dicha
fórmula por pura intuición entonces
inicialmente si te das cuenta no aparece
nuestra fórmula pero para de uno aparece
aquí en el numerador en el denominador
donde aquí arriba está siendo sumada a
la tasa y está elevada al cuadrado
entonces para una sigma alta
de uno va a crecer si sigma es alta de
uno crece y en nuestra parte de dedos va
a ser diferente también tenemos en el
numerador y en el denominador pero aquí
está restando esta parte de aquí
entonces si es muy alta nuestra sigma de
2 va a bajar porque el numerador está
restando esta tasa la sigma cuadrada
entonces para una sigma alta nuestro de
2 va a ser menor y para una sigma alta
de 1 va a ser mayor y entonces se va a
reflejar en esta parte de aquí que de 1
va a ser mayor para nuestra función de n
que está enfocada a de 1 y multiplica al
precio del subyacente entonces lo que
obtenemos va a ser mayor y para de 2 si
es una alta volatilidad de 2 va a ser
menor que es la función de n evaluada en
de 2 x el precio de ejercicio y entonces
lo que pagamos se hace menor así que
para alta volatilidad el precio de
nuestra acción
nuestra opción perdón es alta la opción
de compra el valor de nuestra opción de
compra europea entonces va a crecer así
como al mismo tiempo si la volatilidad
de nuestra opción es más baja el valor
de la opción de compra bajará y lo
dejaré hasta aquí creo que en este vídeo
pues me voy a enfocar en futuros vídeos
en poner esta parte de aquí con un
ejemplo para poder llevarlo a cabo de
una mejor forma
nos vemos al próximo